[Musique]
on y vient rarement de guetté de cœur et
pourtant les saintpaulois sont bien
contents qu'il soit là vous avez reconnu
le centre hospitalier Gabriel Martin une
vierge en face la mairie est à de pas
Gabriel Martin lui est-il encore quelque
part dans la mémoire des
passants savez qui était Gabriel Martin
non c un directeur
conna un chercheur un scientifique oh
tout c'est le ma donne le nom bien c'est
un président il y avait une maison au
bout de là-bas mais je sais pas trop
après ça Gabri il est mort qui c'est qui
fait un hôpital si c'est pas un docteur
je vois pas il était ma aussi tout
ça
Gabriel Martin est né à Saint-Paul en
juillet 1880 après de brillantes études
secondaires à Saint-Denis il part à
Montpellier il en revient en 1906
diplôme de médecine en poche il installe
son cabinet dans la maison familiale et
soigne aussi les indigeens au
dispensaire des Trois Bassins le médecin
de la commune est dispensé de la grande
guerre mais au sortir du conflit il est
bouleversé par un drame personnel la
mort de myiam sa fille unique de 12 ans
emportée par la typhoïde il ne partage
cette épreuve qu'avec ses proches dont
le docteur Raymond vergess mais cette
amitié sera battu en brèche par leurs
choix politiques opposés car à 45 ans
l'élégant médecin sur les traces de son
père s'investit en politique le 27
septembre 1927 il est élu conseiller
général de Saint-Paul fort de ce succès
il remporte les élections municipales de
1929 il décrochera même en 1934 la
présidence du conseil général le docteur
saintpaois aime le pouvoir et règne sans
partage jusqu'au front
populaire à la tête d'un front
républicain il est alors boouté hors du
conseil
général Gabriel Martin encae mal le coup
et démissionne de son poste de maire sa
carrière politique est brisée il
poursuit en revanche sa carrière
professionnelle jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
à quelques jours de ses 82 ans le
docteur Martin
s'éteint
[Musique]
ù